[Music]
let's go to ann in cincinnati what's up
ann how are we doing
hi dr john it's nice to talk to you
today it is nice to talk to you how are
things going
uh going pretty well good good what's up
how can i help
um so i would like to know how to best
be there for my teen stepdaughter
as she works through some relationship
issues with her mom
wow okay so how long have you all been
in each other's life or let me
say that a little less complicated how
long have you been in her life
about 11 years okay so you've been in it
for a while
yeah tell me about it
um so she's 14
and
um she's just the best kid ever she
really is
um and
we knew from early on that like her mom
just wasn't very dependable
and so we just kind of took over
everything like we we never depended on
her for anything
um we being you and the 14 year old are
you and your husband my husband and i
okay um yeah because i mean up until a
couple years ago you know she thought
her mom hung the moon and so we never
told her any different
but you know you would see her at
sporting events or school events and
she's watching the door and like just
seeing the anxiety on her face because
her mom's not there her mom's showing up
late you know it just
i knew that this day was gonna come but
it just it sucks
um
so
last year
um our daughter came to us and said that
she was depressed and suicidal
so
we got her into a doctor and then within
a few days she was admitted into
inpatient treatment
and it took about
six months of weekly sessions and
violate then bi-weekly sessions for her
to really
no longer be have suicidal thoughts but
then with all of that
came out a lot of the issues that she's
had with her mom
and so you know we never want to say
anything bad about her but it's hard to
be truthful and
political and then
so all of that kind of came to a head
over the summer it was my daughter's
birthday
and
um it was actually like we have 50 50
custody and it was actually her week
with her mom but her mom
my daughter wanted like a special dinner
made for that i make
so i asked her mom can i make dinner for
and then like your family can come over
have dinner with our family and she was
like you know we don't want to come but
you can still do that so like we get
along great we all work well together
um
so
then after my daughter got back to her
house that night
um she found out like her mom hadn't
done anything for her for her birthday
so no gift um
like nothing and all she had asked for
was like a 30 video game so then the
next day
it kind of blew up my husband kind of
blew up on her
and you know was asking why she didn't
get her anything for her birthday at all
and she was like well i'm getting
married soon i don't have the
money so
um
it like everything just kind of it got
out in the open then and um so we have a
lot of open conversations with um our
daughter
and you know she's confided in me and a
lot of stuff so
you know i just
i get to where like when she's talking
to me about these things like you know
again like i don't want to say anything
bad about her mom
i don't know where the line is and she
does vent to me quite a bit
so i just i've tried to get better about
just listening and not giving her
any advice at all but i feel like i just
i just don't know what to say
man i appreciate your heart so much
that's awesome
i really do because the t i can imagine
you love this man you love this little
girl
and your instincts are to
like i'll solve this problem you know
what i mean yeah and yeah the restraint
you're showing is it's just unbelievable
it's it's noble and i'm grateful for you
um
so your instincts are right and even
when it's hard i'll always double back
on don't ever talk about about mom
there is a difference between
stating facts
and talking bad about mom
so there is a
i can imagine a scenario where it would
feel really good and you'd be justified
to
in a few months be like can you believe
your mom didn't even get you a present
and
have your daughter say i know and you
did and dad did that would feel good it
would feel like you're winning right but
it's not a competition
there's a difference between
when your daughter says hey i wanna i
don't wanna get my hopes up last year
mom didn't get me anything and you going
yeah she she didn't last year she was
having some financial issues and she
didn't get you anything she loves you
though
um that's one way to handle it versus i
know can you believe she just forgot you
right one of those is a fact
and i'm just stating the fact and do you
and i think that's a character's
attention yeah absolutely um but i'm
just stating the facts that's one way to
do it right and i think that's
completely okay if you don't do that
your kid will feel like she's crazy
like she's having this experience with a
woman who's not
saying i love you and not demonstrating
it
and
nobody in her world will acknowledge
that that that makes her feel nuts but
that's different than talking crap about
it right is that fair
yeah and another thing that like so she
had actually
after that happened she had invited her
to one of her counseling sessions
and
said like i don't feel seen and i don't
feel heard by you um
you know like we don't do anything
together unless i suggest that my
daughter was saying that
so they have this plan in place to do
more you know things together things
that don't cost any money
and um and then her mom just never yeah
that's never going to happen yeah
absolutely not yeah
and i tried to talk to her about like
well you may just have to grieve you
know like you suggest grief
that's not the mom you have and
she's just she's not ready to give up on
it and it just
it's like knowing your child's gonna
break their arm and just watching it
happen yeah
except it's their mom and so they're
they're they're breaking their soul
right yeah
and especially you want to just rattle
that other adult and say for god's sake
show up to the park what else are you
doing
right this is it i know that she loves
her yeah
well but there does come a point when
i'm gonna say that your actions your
behavior is a language and your actions
are telling me you do not love this kid
you love to say that you love this kid
but you are not demonstrating that
and the the devastating thing for you i
mean i love that analogy i've never
heard it before but i love it
you're watching a car wreck happen
and you know that your daughter is going
to continue to try to solve that gap
that her mom has placed between them
because it's mom's job to make sure that
daughter knows that she's loved and is
valued even if she doesn't live in that
house and mom is choosing not to do a
little thing like go to a park with a
kid or show up to a game or something
like that right they're choosing that
and
that your daughter's gonna continue to
try to solve that
and solve that and solve that
so i do think it's fair to have
conversations like
that's not your responsibility or that's
not your job
she's still gonna do it anyway because
she's 14 and she's trying to figure out
what about her is so unlovable that her
own mom doesn't love her
um but i think it's it's continuing to
lean into that that's not your job it's
not your job and i also think it's real
important to develop this one really
important sentence
thank you so much for sharing that with
me followed by a big hug
okay that phrase
gets you out of having to comment on it
if she asks for your opinion or less
than your opinion
um if she asks for advice then she's
inviting you into this conversation
and even my wife will sometimes ask me
she'll show
are you asking for my what i think you
should do in this moment
and when that happens i'm gonna give my
i've been invited in i'm gonna give my
adult wisdom here
because i think that's a honorable thing
to do so for instance she says
hey i i was thinking about inviting mom
to this thing but i don't think she's
gonna show up what do you think i should
do
and you can then say
are you asking me if you should invite
your mom to this thing
yes that's what i'm asking you tell me
about the last three or four times
you've invited her to something
she never shows up she always says she's
going to and she never shows up
what about this time is going to be
different
do you still want to give it a shot
great
yeah i'll support you everyone do so but
you're you're teaching her how to think
through these things without you being
like
hell no don't call her she doesn't get
to hang out with you she always stands
does that make sense
yeah yeah it does and
actually happens not so hard i know
that's so hard so hard isn't it
yeah it really is
um because i am a fixer and
but i've just you know realized that
that's not gonna help her as she gets
you know older and into as being an
adult so
it's just it's just it's awful to you
know watch your kids suffer like just
hurt yeah um it is there is a place too
and i i
may get some pushback on that and this
and that's okay i'm not tied to this but
i do think there's a different
conversation dad can have than you can
have
there is some
conversation that he can talk about mom
a little bit
like hey i know your mom stood you up
last night and i'm very sorry that
shouldn't have happened
he can have that conversation because
there's not that sense of competition
and betrayal that your daughter feels
between you and her her mom
and so when there's a
sense of deep mourning and someone's
gotta say something which i do think
that's important someone's gotta speak
up
i know you wanted your mom to come to
the game and i'm so sorry she didn't
show up
i like that conversation happening from
dad
yeah because it doesn't look like he's
trying to make a move and be like so i'm
the good mom it doesn't feel like that
you can hug deeply and say i'm so sorry
that you're disappointed
and that's when dad comes in and says
yeah mom should have showed up and i'm
sorry that she didn't
okay right and i know that's fine line
but he can step up and have some of
those conversations but
all that to say is i know this is so
hard i want you to make sure you're
getting your needs met other places
because the restraint you're showing is
going to be exhausting right
yeah and it's frustrating and you want
to just go i'm doing all this work why
won't she recognize it why is she still
sad over this other lady
well yeah and i
when she was younger i did go through
that
um but really just being completely open
and honest with her like with each other
you know
like she has even said like i know i
have you
but it doesn't change the fact that you
know that's my mom and so it's like
they're not mutually exclusive like you
know yes i do have you but i also want
my mom too you know
and um it's less about oh it's it is i
want my mom but it's more about
i want to know what about me is so
unlovable
yeah and i guess is there a way for us
to
help her yeah because i just i keep
trying to tell her like this has nothing
to do with you because she really
is just such a not a 14 year old who's
just wondering what about me is not
lovable
and she's been diagnosed with uh
automatic negative thoughts
i don't know if that's a
i haven't heard that diagnosis but it
wouldn't surprise me the dsm is pretty
thick um yeah there's like the body will
protect itself
and the one person who's supposed to
show up in your life regard no matter
what is mom and hers isn't and she's got
dad she's got an incredible world-class
stepmom
but there's that voice inside saying
yeah but your mom doesn't love you
and so lots and lots and lots of
physical touch
holding hands lots of hugs daily hugs
um
possibly having a journal that you all
share together like and you may have
heard me talk about this on the show
a journal between um like just between
two women and it she puts it on your bed
and then you write in it and put it on
her bed and it's something you all don't
talk about unless you have like once a
month we're gonna go talk about what's
in the journal whatever but it's a way
to keep a dialogue open because she's 14
now she's about to enter into a season
where she's going to stop communicating
with you
and there may even become a point when
her
hurting her pain has to become
somebody's fault not her mom's and it
will have to become your
you're about to enter into a new season
is what i'm saying so starting now with
some sort of communication tool i love
the idea of a journal that y'all share i
write in it you write in it i write in
it you write in it and she can go back
and see all of the positive
reinforcement you've put in this thing
how great she is how wonderful how much
you love her what a great young girl she
is um what a incredible woman she's
growing into all those things you can
continue to reinforce that and when you
have automatically default to negative
thinking you can spin those things out
but when it's written down you go back
and see it again and you see it again
and you see it again and that's actually
how you over time begin to shift that
default setting
and so i would recommend y'all do
something like that together lots of
physical touch dad getting involved with
a little bit more conversation and at
some point
at some point
maybe dad or you i don't know y'all's
relationship but somebody has a
conversation with mom that says stop
saying you're going to show up and then
showing up you're breaking this girl's
heart it's just too much for her
it's stop breaking the girl's heart just
have the courage to say i'm not coming
i don't want to be a part of your life
don't continue to dangle your
relationship your love out there like a
carrot and this 14 year old's going to
chase it and chase it she's going to
chase it the rest of her life thanks for
loving ann you're awesome